what i want to do is find out from you
lovely people here um what you'd like to
hear a wrap about let's come to this
area first this kind of little white
shape you're putting a hand up that's so
and you went i'm going first well done
good on you because because some you
know that's good yeah vocal i like it
would you like a
toothpaste where are you from
i don't want the life story i just
thought it was a
it was just you said toothpaste like an
australian and i was about to be like
yeah
that is cool that is cool look at that i
love it
yeah now you are exactly um toothpaste
lovely
how how do you do your toothbrushing in
the morning
how do you do it everyone does it
differently in the shower to put the
water on first water after electric
toothbrush down into the pressure
electric toothbrush toothpaste water
water toothpaste yeah i think that's
good
toothpaste water no water toothpaste
water
aren't getting different in ohio that's
why yeah no don't i don't want it too
wet you know i love that we got the
precision then apparently only i enjoyed
that so toothpaste
yeah is there a hand up there yes my
friend
meat spin now for those of you that
don't know meat spin is a website from
what we call the early internet which is
kind of home to things like blue waffle
and goatsee and it was a website where
if you went to meet spin it was a man
just whirling his genitals round like an
so yeah yeah that's correct good thank
you
i like it because sometimes people go
we're going to trick him with this one
no i'm in deviant sir
you you don't take over the world have a
world empire for 250 years then not
bring your children up knowing what meat
spin is
people in ohio they don't know what meat
spin is they know what toothpaste is but
toothpaste and meat spin people in the
middle of the room what would you like a
rap about
i know that's very hard to follow
what you want to ask about
do you say slime
well no i don't think that's what it
means
especially not when i say the thing that
kids play with ejaculation
they do enjoy that don't they that's
fine that's not no officer
toothpaste meat spin
slime i'm not feeling good about this
rap guys i'm not
um let's let's hope these people elevate
our minds from the gutter what would you
like to wrap about
the theater would you like to pick a
playwright or a plane
oh potato potato unfortunately is a food
so it's expansive
orange peel pimp eyebrows
is that a thing or is that just some
words you put together
yeah orange peel pink eyebrows meat
spins white toothpaste
i do wish i'd taken potato i'm very
sorry
and lovely people over here behind like
five sheets of glass what would you like
a rap about
i would say
so
sorry you're from where my dad's from so
it's taken her back um
what did you say
the balti triangle in birmingham okay so
for those of you that don't know a balti
is a type of curry curry is pretty much
the national dish of the united kingdom
a lot of bangladeshi immigrants in the
1960s birmingham was home to a huge
proportion of that demographic the balti
triangle is an area where you can go and
get some of the best curries in the city
very similar to manchester's carry mile
which takes place in russia i'm not
particularly sure where the bulk
triangle is in birmingham but you're the
multi-triangle
okay
this then lovely people get ready for
buzz
and this is going to be a freestyle rap
as i said that's a wrap made up on the
spot based entirely on suggestions not
written not prepared not rehearsed and
never be repeated again and it is going
to be about toothpaste slime meat spin
orange peel pimp eyebrows and the multi
triangle and don't worry you won't be
able to try to be embarrassing
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm glad you're excited because i'm
slightly trepidatious but let's just do
this
three minutes now you'll lose your mind
i'm talking now all the oohs and i view
the slime a tiny little pot i got it
from toys r us i took it to a
kindergarten and all the fuss all the
kids from the ages six months to three
were like oh please chris give this land
to me i said get in a line calm down and
wait and that guy's like why not
ejaculate so i throw him out i don't
want that cheese i give all of the slime
not come to kids they're like yay it's
gooey it's made from elmer's glue you
can mix it the facts i'll tell you and
now this let me move with haste and
who's kind of viscous like i use
toothpaste i like to mix it up would you
ever guess got the blue and the red and
the white refresh with the three stripes
that's the brand that i like but my
grandmother well she's from way back in
time she uses the one that tastes like
pumice stone i find it weird different
brands than we have in our home all our
favorite preferences i'm in your
bathroom looking at your toothpaste dish
all the tiny little residue and you know
i'm judging you what do you not have a
cleaner who's coming through and wiping
it down when you're spitting the seed i
know toothpaste accumulate the crud
stings kinda like one fruit when it's on
your face orange peel pimp eyebrows in
the first place that's great what does
it even mean i want to get my arch done
i am ever so keen i go to my nearest
eyebrow bar i sit down and i say oh mama
would you get a tiny little tangerine
and then a peeler bring it over here yes
i'm going to reveal my job in my pastime
i pimp out hoes so on my face the orange
peel eyebrows goes i can't grow my own i
relax she removes the natural hair with
all the wax she says sorry chris this
spoils to show we don't have an orange
how about a potato now do that's totally
fine for me it's faulty your little
policy wanna get a ball t technically
that's kind of a disaster too spicy for
my tummy i prefer a madrassa or maybe
jalfrezi these all in these of curries
if you've never had the indian food no
need to worry a vindaloo is spicy a
corner is mild over in birmingham my dad
was as a child i can't do that accident
cause it makes you sound unemployable
i'm really sorry that's a fact
unavoidable but if the lads are out on
the piss they're like come on guys let's
go and get into this i know that sounds
north western but they don't know that
all the regions of uk are they're so fat
on the curry in a hurry you'd be feeling
very silly next morning on the toilet
cause you're [ __ ] out the chili and
while you're there you're like oh i
think could i just emulate the website
meat spin i sat on the bog and i've got
time to kill i'll move around here like
a little windmill it's amazing i
recommend all of you all go online after
this and view the balls to go now
swirling so pendulus come back to me
online and we can discuss wow the girth
up is schlong the length of it i really
like it it went fast like a comment
you'll want to watch it again and again
you'll feel cockahoop and you can why
because the gif runs on a loop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]